-Emma!
-Hi!
-Welcome to the show.
-I'm scared.
-You are not.
-No, I'm not. I'm good.
-I'm so happy. This is your
very first talk show.
-My very first.
-But you're very good at --
you're very good at talking,
so this should be fun.
This should be fun for you.
-Yes, I hope so.
-No, yeah, me too.
-I feel chill.
-You do feel good, right?
-Right? Do I look chill?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-First off,
for those who don't know,
can you explain what you do?
[ Laughter ]
-That's, like,
the hardest question for me.
-Yeah, I start off
with the hard ones.
-I know.
I think what I do is I just,
like, put things on the Internet
and just go like this.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
And just hope for the best.
-Just hope for the best.
-But, I mean, YouTube videos,
and you just --
What's the secret?
Why do --
Why do people just love you?
-I, like, truly don't know.
-I think --
-I truly don't know.
-I think it's because
that you're real,
and I think you're honest,
and I can kind of see that.
When I watch it,
I go, "That's real."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-And you're charming.
-You were saying backstage --
I know you have a lot of
20-something fans, but also,
a lot of moms love you.
-I love it.
It's my favorite type of person
to meet that watches my videos.
-Why moms?
-I love the unexpected.
You know what I mean?
-Yeah, you go, "Oh, that's cool
that you love me."
-Exactly.
'Cause I'm like, for sure,
people my age, you know,
I can imagine can relate to me.
But, like, a mom?
-Yeah.
-Love it!
You know what I mean?
-I was talking about you
on our show
because we had Jack Harlow
on the show, and --
-Yes.
I know, I know.
-I know, but I want
to talk about it
because I think it's so --
it was so charming,
and I was like -- I was like,
"Who is this girl?
She's so good."
You were just interviewing
Jack Harlow, and he said, like,
"I love ya," or something,
and you were like --
[ Scoffs ] -- "What?"
Or something.
[ Laughter ]
Your reaction at the end
went viral.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, and we actually
had him on, and I asked him
his thoughts on this.
-Yeah.
-And I just thought maybe
I could have your reaction
of his reaction.
-Great.
-All right, good.
Let's watch the video.
Here's what Jack said about it.
Take a look.
-All right.
-I'll see you in there.
-Can't wait.
Love you. Bye.
-Love ya.
Pfft!
[ Laughter ]
-That's like a piece of art
because there's so many ways
to interpret that.
You know what I mean?
[ Laughter ]
Everyone has a different take on
what was going through her head,
so I'll leave it up
to interpretation.
-Yeah. But do you leave every
interview saying "Love you"?
-Only if I love them.
[ Laughter ]
-Aww!
-Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's...
-That's sweet.
-That's not bad, right?
I like that guy.
-I love it.
-So, what was going
through your head
when he said that?
-Can I be honest?
-Yeah.
-Like, when I'm doing these
interviews, it's blank up here.
Like, I have no thoughts.
And when I go home,
and I watch
the interviews again,
I'm, like, watching
a completely different person.
I have no idea.
I'm not thinking about anything.
And then I'm, like,
reacting to myself.
-Well, I have some interviews
that I thought maybe I could
show some other ones
and just maybe we could
just go through a couple.
-Yeah, for sure.
-Here's you interviewing
Billie Eilish.
Watch this.
-Okay.
-Well, I can't wait to hang out.
-I know.
-We're gonna party it up
in there.
-Please find me in there,
because I don't --
-Oh, I'm going
to run directly to you.
-Okay, good.
-I finish this, and I'm like,
"I'm going to Billie now."
-Okay, good.
-Me and Coachella --
"I'm going to Billie now."
-Please, for real, find me.
-Oh, no, I will.
[ Laughter ]
-Did you find her?
Did you run right to her?
-Funny story that I, like,
just remembered now.
The first person I saw
when I walked in
was actually her brother.
And I actually ran straight
to her brother at that point,
hung out with him.
Then I met up with her later
in the bathroom.
-Oh, you did?
-The Met bathroom thing is real.
-That's where a lot of people
do meet up.
-Oh, yeah.
-Because they're like --
It's just --
These gowns are just gorgeous,
but it takes probably 10 people
to move them around.
-Oh, yeah.
-Bathroom is
a whole different sitch.
-Well, everybody's
in the bathroom for like
an hour at a time because
it takes so long to pee.
Like, getting the dress off
to pee, it's, like, an ordeal.
And after you're done,
you're so tired that everybody's
just hanging out in there,
like, catching their breath.
-Yeah.
-And then,
we go back to the dinner.
-Who were you hanging out in the
bathroom with, besides Billie?
-I was with Billie
and Kendall and Hailey.
It was, like, a powerful,
powerful --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow, that's a girls room, VIP.
-It was girls night.
-That's a VIP there.
This one I just
want to show you quick
and just get your reaction.
This is you with Shawn Mendes.
-Yes.
Well, amazing.
I'll see you in there.
-Thank you.
-Party it up.
You look awesome.
-Thank you.
-"Shauwn" Mendes.
[ Laughter ]
-Now, what --
-Okay.
-Why "Shauwn" Mendes?
-I don't know.
I just love --
I love a Jersey accent, okay?
But, okay, here was
the thing about that.
That's the one that I thought
was, like, the most funny.
Like, I thought something
was gonna happen with that one
when I watched it
because I was, like,
"Why -- Why did I do that?"
-Yeah.
-But then,
the Jack one was the one.
-Jack one was the one.
But "Shauwn" Mendes...
-Shauwn Mendes.
-It makes no --
He's not from Jersey.
There's no reason
to do that to him.
-He's not even --
He's from Canada.
-Yeah.
-Like, it makes no sense.
-Makes no sense at all.
-Yeah, yeah.
-I want to talk about --
Well, you have --
Congrats on your podcast.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"Anything Goes."
But I really want
to get into this,
and explain this to me,
because you have
your own coffee.
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
-Now, here's what I love
about it.
You gave me a couple samples...
-Yes.
-...earlier today,
and I tried one
because it's almost, like --
Mine was like --
It's almost like a tea bag
but it's coffee.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Which is good.
-Yeah.
-You're a big cold-brew person.
-Yes.
-That's your jam.
-And I also loved your animals
that you drew on each bag.
-Yes.
We wanted it to be something
that was, like, inviting.
And, to me,
I've always loved cartoons,
things like that, whatever.
And so, I was just like,
"Let's do a character
for each coffee blend
so that people can, like,
connect with something."
You know what I mean?
-They can pick their character.
Like, I'm Sleepy Sloth.
-Exactly, exactly.
-Here's Sleepy Sloth.
-No, but I think you're the dog.
-What is the dog's name again?
-Social Dog.
-Oh, Social Dog.
-And you're quite a social dog.
-Oh, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-No, but, like, in a good way.
That's not bad, okay?
[ Applause ]
-It's a dog.
-No, no.
-It's like a dog.
Like, good boy.
Good boy.
-Yeah, yeah.
-A social dog.
-You're great.
So, yeah.
-High energy type of dog.
-Yes, but also,
you're, like,
the most social person
I've ever met.
-Yeah, I do talk a lot.
-You talk to everybody
all the time.
You're very social.
-Yeah.
You brought me your favorite.
-What is your -- who are you?
-Okay.
So I'm the bird.
I'm an early bird.
I do wake up early, so I'm not,
like, just saying that.
-You do?
How early.
-Honestly, today, 6:30.
-Wow, that's good.
-Pretty good.
-Yeah, I like that.
-I'm also jet-lagged,
so I'm cheating.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-But let's just --
you know, whatever.
-And you brought me Social Dog?
-Yeah.
-With a little almond milk?
-Yeah,
that's what I'm talking about.
Let's try it.
-Cheers.
I'm gonna be honest with you.
[ Laughter ]
-Unbelievable.
Off the chain.
I love it.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Two thumbs up.
Earlier today, we sent our pal
Emma Chamberlain
down to the 30 Rock Plaza
to give out
some free coffee to New Yorkers.
But in order to get a free cup,
they had to give her
something in return --
their deepest secrets.
This is "Barista Confessions."
Check it out.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Barista confessions ♪
-So, are you willing to tell me
a secret
in exchange for a coffee?
-I think, for a coffee, I will.
-Okay. Let's hear it.
-My grandparents,
my mom-mom and pop-pop,
they met in prison.
-Badass. Badass.
-Thanks so much, girl.
-Thank you so much.
-Not many people know
but I accidentally set
just a random stranger, a
woman's, hair on fire at a bar.
Yeah. I was doing a trick
with a matchbook.
-Okay.
-And I guess she had
a lot of hair spray.
-Totally flammable.
-She went up.
-You really deserve a coffee.
-Thanks.
-So I listened to the advice of
a witch on TikTok.
Now I have the name of a guy
I used to hook up
with two years ago in a jar full
of maple syrup under my bed.
-Obsessed.
Okay.
-He was supposed to be
"stuck on me."
-I have a really gorgeous aunt.
But in middle school,
I took her photo
and all of her personal
information
and I made multiple Jdate
profiles with it.
So not one but two men
named Simon
have invited her
to live in Israel.
-So you're gonna get
one of these.
-Thank you.
-I hooked up with
my ex-best friend's sister.
-So does your best friend know?
-God, I don't think so.
-Now they do.
-Yeah, I was, like, walking home
from work one day
and I was like three blocks away
from home.
-Yeah.
-And all of a sudden it hits me.
And I'm like, "Oh, no!"
-I know. I've been there.
-"I have to go."
And, like, I pooped my pants.
-This won't help you with
the pooping problem,
but I love this story.
That was good.
[ Cheers and applause ]